et avec nous pour aller plus loin sur ce
sujet ce soir frédéric bornes ce
bienvenu même à distance
j'espère que la liaison fonctionnera
bien vous êtes donc philosophe
professeur de philosophie contemporaine
à l'école normale supérieure vous êtes
membre du comité consultatif national
d'éthique et vous êtes l'auteur de ce
livre
sidération et résistance face à
l'événement 2015-2020 sidération et v10
et résistance j'ai envie de dire sont
les deux mots qui font malheureusement
notre quotidien en ce moment depuis 2015
on est régulièrement sidéré on tente de
résister alors pour certains politiques
c'est ce qu'on voyait dans le sujet la
résistance au terrorisme ça doit passer
par un durcissement des lois j'imagine
que c'est un réflexe humain mais est ce
que il s'agit d'un réflexe justement il
y a plusieurs réflexions
certains sont légitimes et faire simple
ils sont moins le premier réflexe donc
et la fédération elle-même c'est d'être
un peu dans la stupeur ça c'est
malheureusement assez assez grave et on
oublie aussi cette étape cette étape qui
nous pétrifie et sur laquelle il va
falloir aussi travailler résister pour
retrouver nos esprits le deuxième
réflexe je pense est celui-là il y est j
team aussi c'est un réflexe je dirais de
légitime défense
et il ya dans les notions de légitime
défense de l'urgence aussi quelque chose
qui les lie thing les réponses
exceptionnelles qui justifient aussi
qu'on qu'on résiste au sens où on refuse
on se bat contre ce qui vient en effet
de nous agresser
puis un troisième réflexe que je trouve
lui dangereux et c'est vraiment une
question de aussi du rapport au temps et
de chercher à généraliser petit veau
pour l'exception pour la légitime
défense
pardon du son mais on a bien fait guère
de garder mon ordinateur
d'accord et donc voilà le vrai danger
c'est décidé de généraliser tout de
suite
au fond ce qui vaut seulement dans la
période un peu exceptionnel période
exceptionnelle que pour ma part je
définirais avant tout par la question de
la légitime défense légitime défense on
sait bien quand on est attaqué il faut
il faut il ya des règles qu'on peut
suspendre pendant un moment il ya
d'ailleurs la règle même tu ne tueras
point la seule exception c'est si on
m'attaque pour me pour m'assassiner
g
après tout sera examiné par les lois et
le rhône belloy justement c'est plutôt
de rétablir la normale après la période
d'urgence et d'exception et je crois
qu'effectivement pour échapper à la
sidération il pour le moment de la
légitime défense
et puis après le rétablissement des lois
des lois qui généra livre l exception
pas tous leurs effets un remède plus
grave que le mal frédéric formes sont
résistent aussi en rendant des hommages
on l'a encore vu aujourd'hui on
réaffirme en nos valeurs la liberté
d'expression en réaffirmant nos codes
aussi dont fait partie la caricature est
ce que là aussi c'est une bonne façon de
résister oui la principale façon de
rester à la fois outreau matinée à la
guerre c'est la culture sens très large
cadijo fonde le langage la parole la
compréhension le symbolique et de ce
point de vue là aussi bien les dommages
que la discussion ne que l'école et même
la politique au fond ce sont importantes
c'est à dire au fond la politique en
tant qu elle qu'elle essaye de
construire une réponse avec des options
ont posé quand on sort de l'urgence il
ya l'unité dans le moment de l'urgence
et puis après ben heureusement il ya
quand même du désaccord et donc de
désaccord légitime entre position
démocratique donc au fond oui tout ce
qui peut d'abord reconstituer l'unité
mais autour d'un symbole bien clair et
et deux institutions qui l'incarnent
puis reconstitués du débat politique
tout ça fait partie du remède du remède
à long terme et la france comme d'autres
pays le fassent bien parce que fédéraux
m il va pas d'hier qu'on a quand même
construit face à des crimes très graves
l autre même si on va jusqu à réaffirmer
la liberté de blasphémer qui elle
froisse et fâchent des millions de
personnes
ça va jusque là alors si vous voulez là
pour moi l'essentiel et ce qui colle
aussi le terrorisme toujours fait
d'arriver à distinguer les faire de
discours et le terrorisme vient toujours
d'une confusion et d'un refus du
politique c'est la religion qui est
respectable en elle-même mais qui veut
entrer dans nos politiques et la laïcité
ou la liberté d'expression ça repose
d'abord sur cette distinction là et ça
veut dire qu'il ya une distinction aussi
du langage des catégories la liberté
d'expression elle a des limites
mais la limite n'est pas défini par la
religion c'est pas
c'est pas le blasphème la limite c'est
une incitation à la haine et salue donc
la liberté d'expression n'est pas
infinie mais les limites à la liberté
d'expression sont définis par la
politique puisque c'est une liberté
politique et donc on a défini par
l'appel à la haine est une caricature
par exemple qui appelleraient à
assassiner des gens qu'ils soient
religieux ou autre il faudrait
l'interdire
absolument donc là la différence à bien
comprendre c'est que la religion a son
propre ses propres catégories
elle a le droit de dire ça c'est du
bluff times parle et ça vaut pour ceux
qui appartiennent la liberté
d'expression à d'autres limites qui sont
fortes aussi très forte et qui sont
celles liées à l'incitation à la haine
qui ont été construites malheureusement
à coups de transgression à coude
incitation aux moeurs à coups de racisme
et autres discriminations dont ont su
faire confiance aux lois elle construire
leurs propres limites et huiles non ça
n'est pas la limite légale ça n'est pas
de la scène mais l'incitation à la haine
suffit à lutter contre ce que les
religions à plein le blasphème vous
voyez donc c'est toujours pareil il faut
il faut bien distinguer les ordres et le
terrorisme mais toujours une volonté
d'empiéter sur la politique c'est
toujours un refus de la politique
certains dire le terrorisme à des motifs
politiques en fait le geste du
terroriste c'est toujours celui qui
refuse la politique
on l'a vu en encore aujourd'hui la
menace est double elle est sécuritaire
on en a parlé elle est aussi sanitaire
est ce qu'on est aujourd'hui capable de
résister à ces deux menaces
est ce qu'il y à un risque d'épuisement
psychologique est ce que c'est un
concept qui existe pour toute une nation
alors en un sens évidemment c'est une
période inédite par cette multiplication
de danger et même de traumatismes
potentiel mais je pense que on peut
aussi construire une réponse commune à
tous les dangers parce qu'ils ont
quelque chose de commun et en même temps
ils sont différents donc cela nous fait
malheureusement sortir aussi de l'autre
on va voir tout ça comme un empilement
mais qu'est ce qu'ils demandent comment
fond cette question de l'urgence et
cette question de ne pas être écrasé par
l'urgence dans la pandémie par exemple
et bien évidemment il ya des réponses
d'urgence
la question ce qui n'écrase pas toute la
vie et qu'il ne permette là aussi un
retour à la politique que
on arrive à circonscrire l'urgence comme
celle-là c'est un petit peu pareil c'est
une légitime défense aussi le consultant
en un certain sens et donc il faut
accepter que l'urgence est décidé
collectivement mais qu' elle va être
provisoire ensuite on va non seulement
revenir à la vie d'avant mai on espère
avoir amélioré des protections car après
chaque crise il ya quand même aussi dans
une société démocratique qui n'est pas
en guerre
et c'est une condition importante dans
une société démocratique qui arriva à
construire ces outils collectivement il
ya aussi des progrès donc pour moi que
la santé soit reviennent au profit des
plans ça n'est pas ça n'est pas une
tragédie ski tragédie c'est le même
contexte la maladie c'est la pandémie
faisons de cette bande et lui d'abord là
aussi en deux temps réflexe dans le
moment légitime défense confinement et
puis construction en suite d'un ordre
fondé sur le progrès et surtout sur la
distinction entre l'exception et la
règle est la règle c'est ce qui nous
rend humain les uns et des autres puis
ce qui fait que le criminel c'est pas un
criminel par essence il à transgresser
la règle il faut le punir c'est le
certains mais en même temps il n'y a pas
d'identité criminelle on ne met pas
crise on le devient parfait va-t-on
nommé responsable je vais pas excusé
mais fait pas non plus la guerre sauf
que ça pousse tout un pays à gérer
quotidiennement leurs certitudes une
double incertitude est ce que ça doit
nous pousser à nous préparer des actions
à plus long terme est ce que ça doit
dire ce que nous dirigeons un rôle à
jouer
alors pour moi c'est fondamental et
c'est vrai que moi je le critique parce
qu'il fait dans l'urgence je suis pas ni
médecin ni président de la république
mais par contre c'est vrai que
construire l'agenda construire les
institutions qui nous permettent de
travailler sur l'urgence ensemble ça je
pense que c'est encore très perfectible
c'est vrai que je fais partie de ceux
qui sont un peu surpris que depuis huit
mois
disons soit un peu gouverner on est a pu
construire des câbles pour anticiper
l'urgence sais pas si vous vous souvenez
mais avant le tout début de la pandémie
en france on avait des plans des plans
avec deux scénarios un deux trois et on
disait au présent deux cas on sera passé
dans le 2 puis dans le 3 nafa nous
rassurait jeu structuré le temps et là
je pense qu'on a besoin effectivement
comme satan
certainement durer on espère abbado ri
quand même plus comme la grippe comme
comme la peste
ces deux extrêmes elle va rester à bas
bruit il faut absolument construire les
institutions qui nous permette de de
progrès faits moi je crois beaucoup à la
santé publique comme construction
collective
il se trouve que l'attendent elle n'est
pas là par hasard il y aura après une
deuxième crise mondiale probablement
sanitaire d'un autre ordre le climat ou
les polluants divers les produits
toxiques
voilà donc la santé publique un
instrument de progrès parce que pour
être dans une société saine il faut une
société éduqué comme ça a été dit soit
une société de gens qui respectent les
règles parce qu'il est partage parce
qu'ils y sont associés donc il faut ni
démocratie faut aussi définir des seuils
dans tous les domaines vitaux moi je
suis surpris quand même qu'on n'arrive
pas dans les domaines les plus vitaux
qu'on soit encore dans les tours rien si
vous voulez dans les ehpad on a réussi
là vraiment l'ennemi un problème entre
le 1er et le 2ème confinement on arrive
à dire on va pouvoir concilier au fond
va pouvoir concilier la maladie d'un
côté et puis l'amour la visite à nos
proches je pense que dans tous les
domaines il faut maintenant définir des
lignes de consensus et de conciliation
de tout ce qui est important pour nous
on ne peut plus nous dire c'est la santé
où l'amour c'est la santé ou le reste de
la vie un peu plus ce n'est pas même pas
de l'économie on ne peut plus me forcer
à vous tout au rien dans aucun domaine
vous parliez de faire des plans vous
parliez du long terme vous et thoniers
que les dirigeants n'est pas mieux prévu
les choses mais est ce que tout ce qui
fait notre démocratie n'est pas mise à
mal les institutions les médias la
liberté d'expression la justice
aujourd'hui même la parole des experts
des médecins est mise en doute
est ce que la démocratie juste en crise
où elle est carrément à l'agonie moment
du tout pas du tout je pense au
contraire que les ailes et f t on à
faire pas faim bien sûr mais c'est elle
qui leva et sa fille mais la médecine
n'a pas du tout n'est pas du tout en
fidèle à l a progressé à une vitesse
extraordinaire elle fait des essais
cliniques beaucoup plus vite qu'avant
tout en respectant les règles
on a une leçon de philosophie des
sciences en temps réel sur nos écrans
sur vos écrans grâce à vous on progresse
dans la prise de conscience d'une
culture scientifique qui avait qui
étaient en voie de disparition
donc c'est vrai dans gym danger c'est la
démagogie c'est très clair le danger
c'est c'est ceux qui se réjouissent de
cette crise vous de la crise
elle est là et il faut la construire y
répondre avec ce qu'ils comprennent ce
qui est menacée et puis malheureusement
dans une crise humaine il ya ceux qui
cherchent à en profiter ou à en jouir de
manière un peu perverse
il ya ceux qui jettent de l'huile sur le
feu il ya le faut mais il a les
pyromanes les auteurs divine moi je suis
plus inquiété par eux et par les frais
parce que les faune et les humains ont
construit mais les casernes de pompiers
et les outils d'en construire d'autres
même les gars des pyromanes cela il faut
les comprendre et les pyromanes on l'est
on les observe tous les jours on les
voit tous les jours notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux quelle est la place des
réseaux sociaux dans votre réflexion
le central elle est centrale parce que
c'est elle qui en fait le premier pas ce
qu'il y'a pas un danger plus les réseaux
sociaux qui sont en bas je pense qu'au
contraire sur ma un danger et qu'on peut
faire confiance à ceux qui s'en occupent
eh bien il va pas disparaître par magie
bien sûr et si on peut critiquer aussi
de manière légitime confiance suppose
aussi la critique
ça va aller mais si on a un danger et
que par ailleurs chacun est dans son
coin appel à la culpabilité des autres
et à la guerre de tous contre tous là on
n'arrivera plus à traiter aucun danger
donc oui je pense vraiment que c'est
maintenant que le premier danger
mon autre raison c'est que comme vous
savez les leçons doute dans l'histoire
du monde ya déjà eu de propagande
massive
il ya des théoriciens pendant le même
film qui ont dit de la ville mme c'est
la propagande et la propagande créer un
univers parallèle un univers qui double
le monde réel et au fond et c'est ça le
vrai danger il faut prêtre comme on
passe réduire les catastrophes mais les
catastrophes en souffre il faut une
catastrophe on a l'impression pour qu'un
peu de réelle perte
ce mur du son cet écran de fumée c'est
l'écran de plus mais qui sont maintenant
ceux des réseaux sociaux donc oui je
crois vraiment que c'est le premier des
dangers
et je suis surpris qu'ils résistent pour
certains bon évidemment quand il ya des
présidents au pouvoir qui est qu'ils
sont bébés dictateur aussi ça peut
expliquer mais il résiste même à la
pendule y fait quand même très
impressionnant
moi je fais partie de ceux qui tant fait
qu'une façon d'une gravité telle et
mettre un peu de réelles justement de
rationalité dans ce discours je pense
qu'à long terme ça va être le cas mais
qu'il faut absolument irréaliste elle
est chaque jour un peu chacun partout la
roue non mais c'est à dire qu'elle dont
j'ai exactement si on veut être un peu
précis c'est quoi c'est le danger du
livre ensemble c'est sur quoi ça peut
déboucher à la wii fait le bond du bouc
émissaire c'est le danger de déplacer
les problèmes au lieu d'un problème
comment vers l'accusation de tel ou tel
autre quel danger aussi du délit c'est
très curieux parce que les réseaux
sociaux sont à la fois dans la panique
est dans le déni
ils sont dans l'aggravation de certains
dangers qui sont réels mais qui ne sont
pas forcément les premiers ou les plus
graves et le béni de certains autres aux
états unis les réseaux sociaux font
parfois croire à faire pas que les
migrants mexicains sont plus graves que
la pandémie
on ne dit pas qu'il ya pas de problème
je suis entre un ministre et un problème
par rapport à un autre
mais on a quand même un sentiment d'
inversion des valeurs pour des raisons
avant tout deux de manipulation
politique et je pense qu'effectivement
de l'alternative aux réseaux sociaux
c'est la discussion c'est la
construction des problèmes moi je crois
vraiment que il faut pas tous ceux qui
prétendent avoir des solutions se
trouvent à touches sont forcément dans
les reins méfions-nous de seuil qui ont
des solutions d'e bay nos craintes sur
ce qu'ils ne disent pas j'étais la
solution pour tous et qui vive
essayons de comprendre quel est le
problème essayant de comprendre quel est
le problème avec les messageries et
réseaux sociaux c'est vrai par
définition se pose pas trop de questions
des salaires de rien c'est
malheureusement très dangereux frédéric
devance vous avez beaucoup travaillé je
crois sur la notion de moments que vous
différencier de celle de l'instant
comment vous définiriez le moment que
nous vivons est ce que c'est un moment
charnière est ce que on entend beaucoup
le mot historique moment historique est
ce qu'il est vraiment il
ricks moment d'après vous c'est vrai que
moi ce que j'appelle moment définition
la 4l d'original jeu séduisant une
période de l'histoire qui fait rupture
avec ce qui a précédé libel moment cédé
dès que l'histoire mais pas à tout d'une
traite mais qu'il ya des ruptures il ya
des discontinuités bon et pour moi ça
peut être fait par des événements
certains ont une conception événementiel
des moments il ya un grand événement une
guerre qui coupe en deux l'histoire il
ya deux ans et un après ce sera plus
jamais comme avant est pour moi un
moment et heureusement c'est jamais
seulement des événements mais c'est
aussi des changements de problèmes
généraux de conditions je crois que
depuis trente ans on est entré dans ce
que j'appelle le moment du bilan les
lumas réalisme ne sont pas coupés du
monde que l'histoire humaine n'est pas
une construction de la liberté de la
cité parfaite en se fâchant à la nature
comme on l'a beaucoup cru y compris dans
les grandes versions aussi bien libéral
que marxiste d'ailleurs le
transhumanisme est une prolongation du
libéralisme qui croient qu'on va
échapper à la nature le marxisme croyais
qu'on avait pouvoir échapper aussi à
notre servitude matériel bon c voilà on
est comme à quitter ces grands moments
succombé sur la philosophie de
l'histoire et on est revenu à des
questions sur le vivant sur la nature
d'abord avec des aspects négatifs mais
je crois qu'il ya aussi des aspects
positifs et n'oublions pas qu'à un
moment comme celui que nous vivons ce
toujours aussi des découvertes
scientifiques sur le cerveau sur les
virus ou s'il va y en avoir qui l'est un
entretien une chercheuse brésilienne qui
disait que les virus avait pouvoir aussi
servir à guérir des mallettes que la
recherche qui se passe en ce moment va
aussi avoir on sait que les recherches
autour de face à d'autres présenter des
dangers imprévu elle a aussi des
bienfaits imprévus en tout cas un moment
ça une épaisseur et on n'est pas perdu
je pense que ce dont on a besoin de
s'orienter plus que tout on a besoin de
comprendre
est-ce qu'on assiste à une accélération
de ces moments et du coup l'un chasse
l'autre on oublie on en oublie
l'importance l'ampleur comme on oublie
ma
heureusement certains attentats parce
que il ya tellement d'attentats qu'on
n'oublie l'un après l'autre et ce qu'il
ya ce risque
en fait il ya une multiplication
d'événements mais leur répétition même
confirme l'idée qu'il ya quelques grands
problèmes structurels qui définissent à
un moment la répétition est en effet
traumatisante quentin atlanta revient
que jamais toujours au même endroit où
l'impression d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
sorte de manager ni qui viennent à
chaque fois une cible symbolique
différente une église
les 14 juillet un bar et j'en passe
malheureusement il peut y en avoir
d'autres
l'enseignement évidemment donc il ya des
choix différents mais la répétition
confirme qu'il ya un problème et ce
problème c'est effectivement un
apprentissage de la démocratie
elle dénie de la politique dans certains
discours religieux extrêmes donc
peut-être potentiellement dans toute l'
tout chaque religion que l'engendré
cette dérive
mais c'est vrai que il ya un problème de
fond est fait pas juste des répétitions
d'événements vos recherches portent
aussi sur les relations vital et moral
entre les hommes
alors s'il ya bien une chose que
bouleverse virus sont nos relations
interhumaines est-ce que du coup ça doit
nous pousser à réinventer notre relation
à l'autre
oui tout à fait moi quand je parle de
relation du talent et morale c'est
d'ailleurs en sens opposé les bains et
relation vitale vivons ça peut être le
soin j'ai effectivement j'ai beaucoup
travaillé les médecins une pratique
évidemment mais aussi les parents les
humains pour survivre et donc être ce
genre de relation vitale mais les
relations moral par exemple l'amitié de
l'amitié ou l'amour ou l'éducation sont
aussi vital il se trouve qu'une vital de
tafer simple est vital ce dont se
bourrer l'absence nous ferait mourir
vous voulez on dit que le par le vital
et da l'amour aussi et c'est trouver un
par la psychologie expérimentale
nous risquons humain qui n'est pas du
tout et met son corps va peut-être
subsistait mais en fait il ya pile
endurera quelque chose peut-être
mammifères que la main bon les relations
qu'on dit maurane
parti de la vie humaine c'est pourquoi
je suis tel accompagnement des proches
ou bien même le fait de pouvoir se voir
et se parler comme aussi vital que les
dix cas mangou la nourriture
donc oui c'est vrai on est en train de
s'apercevoir en ce moment que c'est pas
si facile de limiter ce qui est vital
pour les humains me dire juste la survie
eh bien non en même temps dire la
liberté plutôt que la santé d'un non
plus parce que si l'on ne peuvent pas
vous êtes aussi les rêves pour ça donc
ce qu'il faut c'est consigné tout ce qui
est vital pour les humains mais alors
est-ce que ce reconfirme en est une
bon équilibre qu'à trouver emmanuel
macron ceux comme on dire confinement
light en tout cas plus léger qui ne
rompt pas complètement nos relations aux
autres puisqu'on continue d'aller
travailler mais on essaie de limiter au
maximum nos relations aux autres et
notamment à nos proches en fait comme on
dit c'est un équilibre mais l'important
c'est qu'ils soient provisoires et que
et qu'on nous donne ce qui m'a frappé
dans l'intervention de maquereau est
très occupé un moment de vérité aussi
c'est quand la vie on y sera encore
allaités 2021
peu de gens ont commenté cette phrase je
crois qu'une fois qu'on a dit ça et je
suis sûr que voilà il y en a conscience
mais il faut construire ce chemin ou un
équilibre quels qu'ils soient un moment
donné qui est pas ça c'est l'abbé civile
qui peut être toujours améliorer ou
voilà mais qui quand même créer quelque
chose de pour l'instant t on revient à
l'urgence est légitime défense qui est
temporaire et bien cet équilibre de
toute façon il doit être remplacé
ensuite par quelque chose qui lie ce
qu'ils puissent tenir la durée keith qui
fasse que l'on prenne en compte vraiment
toutes les dimensions de la vie humaine
dans cet équilibre
il a des défauts je pense que dans son
bétail
il est parfois drôle mais c'est
révélateur moi par exemple j'avais
compris la distinction entre les balles
et les restaurants la trouve cruel pour
les antilles sur le cul elle malgré tout
le restaurant ce nécessaire pour le
travail le bar malheureusement c'est ben
on y mange pas donc on peut entre
guillemets s'en passer mais ça c'est
provisoire
il ya un moment où on doit avoir un peu
de tout fait dire par exemple au lieu de
poser les bars et les restaurants
rail notre limite et on espère
évidemment un jour et ce serait pareil
pour les livres dont on pourrait parler
bon d'une certaine façon oui cet
équilibre j'irai pas pinailler là
maintenant mais par contre si ça va
jusqu'à 2028 indiquent les probables
commençons dès maintenant à à construire
les grands équilibres de l'avenir parce
que l'autre option qu'avait emmanuel
macron c'était aussi de laisser ce virus
circule et comme d'autres pays l'ont
fait emmanuel macron nous a dit oui mais
si on fait ça ces quatre cent mille
morts dans quelques mois
est-ce que ça se discute d'un point de
vue éthique est ce qu'après tout on peut
dire qu'ils avaient le choix qu'il
aurait aussi pu choisir cette option
bien sûr très beau d'ailleurs en
démocratique et d'avoir des choix et au
fond on fait toujours des choix qui
implique aussi de malheureusement dans
des ressources sera de ne pas pouvoir
répondre à tous les besoins vitaux et il
ya effectivement des choix
il ya là toujours là certainement des
maladies rares en france qui ne sont pas
soignées parce que la recherche coûte
trop cher trop trop peu de gens donc on
a dit ces gens là malheureusement
ah oui mais ils sont trop peu nombreux
et en fait l'absolu de la vie humaine
dans ce cas là on est obligé de
relativiser un peu et on est dans le
trafic il ya deux choses à dire c'est
d'abord que c'est tragique et ensuite de
dire des ponts des rangs et je crois que
le côté abstrait des deux de l'autre
mesure celle qu'il n'a pas choisie c'est
de dire mayorat il y aura des morts
c'est pas grave qui aura encore plus de
morts par l'économie ça ne tient pas
compte de l'urgence
heureusement à cette idée nous sommes
responsables maintenant des gens qui
meurent maintenant et qu'on peut éviter
nous sommes responsables des morts
évitables c'est assez clair donc la
responsabilité et là il l'a dit et les
économistes le montre la responsabilité
aussi à une cotisation sacrifices et les
principes
finalement au bout d'un moment ça
devient effective ricolleau jt politique
et la société fera en guerre d'un côté
on peut dire laissons mourir des gens et
l'économie ira bien d'un autre côté on
peut dire aussi laissant mourir des gens
est en train de l'epad guerre civile
parce que plus personne ne sera soutenu
par personne donc l'importance de
maintenir à kde est de distinguer des
moments de reprendre le contrôle de ma
prise par ce virus nous a aussi fait
prendre conscience si on
doute est évidemment de la vulnérabilité
de la vie on peut être terrassé par un
virus microscopique c'est une sacrée
leçon d'humilité pour l'être humain et
son sentiment parfois de surpuissance
d'hyperpuissance sur cette planète
oui bien sûr c'est surtout c'est le fait
que ma l'impression que la médecine qui
qu'on avait construit pour éviter ça est
en échec ce qui est faux en général ce
qui est vrai provisoirement en had su et
ça ça que j'appelle fédération
d'ailleurs c'est quand il ya un pilier
qui nous protégeait qui tombe sésame est
juste la mort ou la vulnérabilité c'est
con tout ce qu'on avait construit semble
s'écrouler mais ça n'est pas le cas mais
nous nous vivons ce moment dans tous les
domaines la maladie d'alzheimer montre
que notre mémoire
la reconnaissance par ceux qui nous
aiment tous à des petites conditions
dans nos cerveaux et qu'une petite
modification de nos circuits neuronaux
attaquants ne reconnaît plus nos enfants
et que tout ce qu'on croit et que notre
voilà qu'un très grand père par exemple
finir je pense à quelqu'un treaty
entrain de barbouiller dans une ehpad
voilà les façons accompagnés par des
aides soignants d'ailleurs mis râble
mais dans un contraste terrible qu'il
imaginait voilà mozart ne se sont en
plus de ses propres oeuvres
donc si vous voulez vivent en ce moment
où nous réalisons dans le détail notre
vulnérabilité
mais justement je pense que voilà il ya
des gens qui critiquent la médecine un
des grands critères de progrès dans
l'histoire de l'humanité ça a toujours
été une société où on vit plus longtemps
et en meilleure santé
vous n'avez pas tellement d'autres
critères du progrès à part la justice la
démocratie la culture et la paix mais la
santé humaine reste le critère de
progression qui croient pas au progrès
c'est possible qu'il accepte la maladie
et des autres ce qu'on vit frédéric
vendre c'est ce sera ma dernière
question va clairement bouleversé et
enrichir votre discipline votre matière
la philosophie j'imagine que c'est une
période inspirante aussi en fait voilà
plusieurs années mais tu parles d'une
demande où vivent plus de 20 ans en
attente c'est vrai que la philosophie
est replacé devancé vigilance moi je l
ai mis un peu de temps à izmir je suis
passé par l'histoire de la philosophie
par différentes choses
qui me frappe moi je travaille à l'école
normale où on forme les jeunes
chercheurs me frappe c'est que les
sujets de thèses d'aujourd'hui sont des
sujets sur lesquels moi je travaille
maintenant comme beaucoup d'autres de ma
génération et que non sont tout de suite
dedans
si vous voulez donc voilà je sais que
les jeunes dont on pour lesquels on
s'inquiète et on a raison
sont aussi en train de construire des
réponses ils iront beaucoup plus vite
encore que que moi que nous sur les
questions de soins de santé publique sur
l'animal sur le vivant ils sont déjà en
droit en lice poivrons philosophie donc
elle compte deux vitesses mais les les
jeunes sont là et je crois
qu'effectivement nous on est on y est le
fils allait dire faible génération aussi
pris 20 points 7 passes où est parti ça
voilà une course phare d'espoir quand
même sur cette projection sur ce que la
jeunesse pourra faire le mans croyons
[Musique]
bien présent merci merci infiniment
fredrik band d'avoir été avec nous pour
cet entretien je rappelle le titre de
votre dernier livre sidération et
résistance face à l'événement 2015 2020